c'est une habitude bien ancrée dans les
restaurants les bars les cafés on offre
un pourboire à la personne qui nous sert
ça dépend si la personne elle est
souriante ou elle m'accueille bien si le
service est très bon ben j'en donne plus
et vous avez peut-être l'impression
d'être plus sollicité qu'auparavant
depuis la pandémie les poutres pour
boire ont été remplacées par des
terminaux de paiement avec l'arrivée des
terminaux les pourboires étaient
programmés ont été programmés souvent
après les taxes donc rapidement on est
passé du fameux 15% dans la restauration
à presque
18%. c'est moi qui choisis soit le
pourcentage ou le montant donc c'est à
m'en juger je fais partie des gens qui
sont un peu gênés
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre est aussi
venue brouiller les cartes alors que les
employeurs cherchent à être plus
attractif ajoutez le pourboire devient
une option intéressante dans des
endroits où typiquement on aurait pas eu
à donner de pourboire bah le terminal ou
la personne tant la main pour vouloir
recevoir du pourboire
mais difficile pour de petites
entreprises de son passé on aimerait
beaucoup pouvoir payer nos employés plus
les reconnaître un peu plus puissants
c'est difficile mais pour boire je pense
que c'est important entre autres pour ça
au café les fraises le pourboire et
partager également entre tout le monde
au service comme à la cuisine ça nous
permet comme une table dans le dos nous
ont servi du pourboire souvent pour
évaluer un petit peu le service dans une
journée mélodie Desjardins rappelle que
c'est un bonus sinon une obligation
comme ces employés ne sont pas
assujettis un salaire à pourboire dans
demeure pas moins que la réflexion sur
la pratique est bien réelle il y a un
mouvement est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
pétitions est-ce que bientôt le salaire
minimum va augmenter
entre temps c'est le consommateur qui
déboursent davantage et qui peut donc
revoir sa façon de faire ici qui me
permettrait au Canada Montréal